U.S President Joe Biden will meet with
Chinese president Xi Jinping on Monday
at the G20 Summit in Indonesia at the
end of a trip that will take him to the
cop 27 climate Summit in Egypt and to
the asean and East Asia Summits in
Cambodia
one issue the President says he wants to
address beijing's expansion of its
military including its nuclear Arsenal I
think talk about nuclear weapons and
location a number of them and access is
important to discuss she and Biden will
also discuss North Korea Chinese trade
policy the response to covet and other
public health threats and global warming
I don't think you should look at this
meeting as one in which there's going to
be specific deliverables announced
rather the two leaders are going to give
direction to their teams to work on a
number of areas both areas where we have
differences in areas where we can work
together competing with and out doing
beijing's International influence is
official U.S policy according to the
recently released U.S national security
strategy quote the contest to write the
rules of the road and shape the
relationships that govern Global Affairs
is playing out in every region and of
course across economics technology
diplomacy development security and
Global governance analysts say not only
will this policy add a layer of tension
to the XI Biden meeting
but Washington cannot assume it has
allies in that fight it's easier said
than done though for sure because so
many of these countries in asean and the
G20 they don't want to be positioned in
the U.S Camp they want to have the
freedom to engage with both the U.S and
China particularly economically Biden
and she's meeting will be perhaps the
most important since Richard Nixon met
with Mao Zedong in 1972 a chance for
both the U.S and China to decide how
their relationship will proceed Rosalind
Jordan Al Jazeera